هل تستعد وزارة الخارجية حاليًا
للتعامل مع فريق بايدن
الانتقالي ، وإذا لم
يكن الأمر كذلك ، فإن التأخير يعيق
الانتقال السلس
أو يشكل خطرًا على الأمن القومي ،
فسيكون هناك انتقال سلس إلى
إدارة رابحة ثانية ،
حسنًا ، نحن جاهزون  يراقب العالم
ما يحدث هنا ، سنقوم بعد
جميع الأصوات
عند اكتمال العملية ، وسيكون هناك
ناخبون مختارون ، وهناك عملية
يحددها الدستور بوضوح تام
، يجب أن يكون لدى العالم كل الثقة في
أن الانتقال ضروري للقيام به
تأكد من أن وزارة الخارجية
تعمل اليوم
بنجاح اليوم وأن النجاح مع
الرئيس الذي
يتولى منصبه في 20 يناير
، سيكون منتصف بعد
الظهر ناجحًا أيضًا
، لقد مررت بمرحلة انتقالية في المقدمة وكنت
في الجانب الآخر من  هذا
أنا واثق جدًا من أننا سنفعل
كل الأشياء الضرورية
للتأكد من أن
حكومة حكومة الولايات المتحدة
ستستمر في الأداء  أو قم
بوظيفة الأمن القومي الخاصة بها
بينما نمضي قدمًا ، لذا فأنت تعتقد أن هناك
تزويرًا واسع النطاق للناخبين بأن التقارير
التي نتلقاها من ولاية بنسلفانيا
من ميشيغان والتي تظهر إجمالي الأصوات والنتائج
الهائلة أو الخيوط المهمة
مع 99 تقريرًا سيتم
إبطالها وأن الولايات المتحدة
فشل
في إجراء انتخابات حرة مزورة
غنية ،
أنا وزير الخارجية ، أتلقى
مكالمات من جميع أنحاء العالم ،
هؤلاء الأشخاص يشاهدون انتخاباتنا ،
وهم يفهمون أن لدينا عملية قانونية
يفهمون أن هذا
يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً استغرقنا 37 عامًا أو أكثر  أيام
في انتخابات عام 2000 التي أجريت
انتقالًا ناجحًا ،
فأنا واثق جدًا من أننا سنحسب
ويجب علينا احتساب كل تصويت قانوني
يجب أن نتأكد من أن أي تصويت لم يكن
قانونيًا لن يتم احتسابه مما يضعف
تصويتك
إذا تم ذلك بشكل غير صحيح ، فسنصلح
ذلك عندما نفهمه بشكل صحيح ،
فسنقوم به بشكل صحيح ، فنحن في
حالة جيدة